[Musique]
salut juste pour info cette vidéo c'est
pas un placement de produit on n'a pas
reçu d'argent pour ça par contre à la
fin de la vidéo je vous fait gagner la
console avec simon alias le jeu vidéo on
chantait bref à la fin de la vidéo on
vous dit comment gagner la console mais
pour l'instant on va l'essayer bienvenue
sur la chaîne mentale gaming et
regardons les regardant la vidéo qu'est
ce qu'on va faire parler ses studios
vrac osseux d'aumale cyril thomas a
perdu est-ce que ça serait pas habituel
tiens je ne sais pas 9e hilarité mais
bon si tu es e match au sénat ont été
faits pour s'entendre
matrix je méprise mon adversaire je
croise le regard déjà tu as tué ma femme
mon chien mais je te méprise vu ce que
vient de dire non il était après l'autre
flash est une merde est une victoire 6 9
je suis imbattable far west est-ce que
j'ai tiré sur toi au moins à ce que au
mois ça soit je crois que oui
par contre j'étais visé le très bas moi
j'ai la décence moi de tirer dans le
coeur tu vois tu mais c'est presque
raciste et presse quasi gel des gars et
je te la mettre dans la tête
[Musique]
le petit scarabée n'a pas de citations
chinoise mais où vous allez me dire une
quand même nom au ciel et diamants voilà
c'est ça c'est quoi c'est quoi c'était
si vous êtes abonnés à la chaîne et
simon pensez à vous tous les abonnés sur
ce que ce mec n'a pas les références des
chevaliers du zodiaque weaver n'est pas
possible à seebach c'est bien ce qui me
semblait scellé chauliac c'est vraiment
car des trucs d'anticipation qui me
permettrait de parler de non verbale en
même temps mais c'est pas le cas du tout
puisque à chaque fois on doit réagir un
signal commun donc on fait quand même la
vidéo parce que ce serait dommage de la
voir cette console à vous faire gagner
et ne pas faire cette console times
je crois que comme si la violence je
pense que quand on leur dit qu'on allait
parler c'est ce à quoi tu la connais tu
vas voir de ma mère je te rappelle
fallait bannir mais bien sûr mais toi tu
es tout sens mentalement par mois je
vais perdre trop lent et hilarante
hockey et chaque fois je l'appelle
entier je veux plus jamais entendre
qu'elle ferait trop rapide détournement
d'attention confusion mentale j'ai
brussels images c'est bon et pourtant tu
étais pas non plus comme celle humiliant
comme gagnant ait dit ça ne vois pas de
quoi alors neville londubat comment vas
tu ne vivent et s'équipe du bon gars au
genre je me fie tonga mais moi je parle
d'eux
gardons expelliarmus tu as vu ce qu'il
va devenir ma vie j'étais trop agressif
d'habitude on fait gagner le coeur de
gauche bien sûr et j'ai la même réaction
aux crises et captain alors notre but
devait faire d'accor ne faut pas le nom
c'était ça ce n'est pas grand-chose à
c'était chaud des trois titres aura des
vignes et ou pas enfin faut le battre
c'est choquant à eau
ainsi s'achève l'humiliation de ce qui
manque au départ j'espérais vraiment que
je pourrais vous donner des indices sur
le non verbal en jouant à deux et puis
en fait comme le genou marche qu'avec
des signaux c'était complètement
impossible complètement tu as possible
mais du coup bah on n'allait pas ne pas
faire la vidéo et on a quand même essayé
de la suite j'ai bien rigolé après moi
je connais pas grand chose non lui il
connaît mieux que moi en vidéo un simon
si vous connaissez pas le jeu vidéo
tu avais fait une vidéo avec moi sur ma
chaîne j'avais faire à quoi tu joues à
rome je vous invite à découvrir sa
chaîne qui est dans la description
fabien est venu parler de civilisation
oui mais voilà j'adore ce jeu et du coup
que oui alors malheureusement j'ai
découvert que après qu'ils avaient de
jeu de bluff dans la console celui avec
les billets celui avec les dés qu'on n'a
pas pu les essayer puisque même temps
simon est reparti à stockholm mais si ça
vous tente je referai une vidéo dessus
je mets à sondages juste là et je
pourrais bien me refaire prêter une
switch pour ça pourquoi prêter parce que
celles ci on va vous l'offrir on vous
l'a dit déjà merci beaucoup à ces 10
contre celle qui nous l'ont envoyé et
nous on a décidé de vous la renvoyez à
vous les abonnés pour ça c'est très
simple je mets un message sur twitter
aujourd'hui et pour participer au tirage
au sort il suffit de le heurter je fais
le tirage au sort dans sept jours to
kill donc samedi d'après et si vous
voulez être cool vous pouvez en même
temps follow cdiscount et follow simon
et me follow mois n'oubliez pas que
demain à 17h30 je fais le live ici sur
la chaîne
je sais que c'est les élections mais
justement ça nous fera passer le temps
en attendant les résultats et pour le
concours du trophée exceptionnellement
il n'y a pas d' indices dans cette vidéo
n'en cherchez pas ne cherchez pas ne
cherchez pas ne cherchez pas je dis
j'espère qu'il y en a qui vont chercher
ne cherchez pas
[Musique]